okay now i don't want to worry people
unnecessarily but we need to be
correctly concerned
correctly concerned that national polls
have tightened donald trump is closer
now to joe biden in national polling
than he has been since may which was
almost five months ago
these polls importantly do not yet take
into account the effect of the first
debate this is still
all pre-debate polling but we have to
acknowledge that it is looking
less good for joe biden today than it
was looking
last month and the month before and the
month before that and if we don't vote
if we don't all vote we may all be
devastated on november 4th so looking at
the average of recent national polling
from real clear politics right now joe
biden's average lead
is 6.1 now on september 11th it was
eight
and on july 27th it was 9.3
and on june 23rd it was 10.2 so this is
not
the right trend now let's let's look at
it in a different way
in chart form so again june 23rd
bidens up 10.2 in the month that follows
by july 27th
biden's lead has dropped by just about a
point to 9.3
by september 11th biden's lead has
dropped to eight
another roughly point and a half and
then between
september 11th and today joe biden's
lead
dropped 1.9 points on average
this is not good this is not good when
you see a lead go from 10.2 to 6.1
in a few months that's a 40
shrinkage of the lead it's not
small there are also some recent polls
that are not exactly giving me too much
comfort i've highlighted some of them
here
on this image which we're showing our tv
audience a recent national poll has
biden
only up by two that's the lowest we've
seen in
a high rated national poll for a while
in wisconsin
joe biden is only up by two that's a
state he had been leading by more
on average biden is still winning but
seeing a poll in which biden's only up
two is not exactly encouraging
north carolina recent poll has trump
ahead after many polls had
biden ahead so this is not
panic oh no but it is this is not nearly
over
none of us should think it is and none
of the polls
sort of price in voter suppression
voter intimidation whatever donald trump
may be able to achieve
through the courts to stop the counting
of absentee ballots
none of that is even in the polls there
are also
some good indicators in the last couple
of days as an exam
example there's a poll out of north
carolina for the senate remember that in
in north carolina you have incumbent
republican tom tillis
defending his seat against democratic
challenger cal cunningham
there's a new poll that has cal
cunningham the challenger up six
in north carolina that's great a poll
out of georgia where democratic giant
challenger john ossoff
is up by one against the incumbent
republican senator
perdue forget what his first name is
senator perdue
in georgia that's very very good but it
is not an exaggeration when i say
every race every state has to be fought
for
figure out how you will vote if you're
interested in voting absentee go to
vote.org
slash absentee hyphen ballot or just
search google for vote.org absentee
ballot it'll take you to a page
you put in your address it tells you how
you in your state request an absentee
ballot it's not too late
if you want to vote early you go to
google you type in vote.org early voting
the first result is a page telling you
how to vote early
in your city or town or locality have a
plan
um we cannot assume anything and when
you look at the
you know whenever i do this i get emails
from people saying david
you are do your gaslighting it's reverse
gas lighting i don't know what that
means gas lighting is gas lighting
you're gaslighting people into thinking
it's close
so that people will vote no i am
accurately telling you
that joe biden's lead in the national
polls has shrunk from 10 to nine to
eight to seven to six
over the last five months now you can
say six is still plenty enough to win
well maybe but what if six becomes five
and then you lose another two points
because of
suppression and biden wins the popular
vote by three but loses electorally then
what was should i have shut up come on
guys okay let's be responsible
we've all got to see the data we've all
got to have a plan here
one of our sponsors today is hydrant and
they're giving my audience 25
off your first order hydrant has been
great for me
it's this delicious electrolyte powder
made with real fruit juice
you mix it into water for great tasting
rehydration
with low sugar packed with electrolytes
but way more cost effective than those
high sugar sports drinks
comes in flavors like lime fruit punch
orange mango
they have no sugar varieties which come
in lemonade and pink grapefruit
they also have a new product line called
immunity which adds vitamins b
c and d and they have a version with
caffeine if you're looking for
that type of boost staying hydrated
helps my focus
and keeps my energy up and hydrant has
been a great way for me to do that as
part of my daily routine
they have a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drinkhydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video